[Music]
on this thursday night confirmation of
unmarked graves at the former
residential school in kamloops
details of what ground penetrating radar
found and the vast
area still to be searched the truth and
reconciliation
what the hell does that mean manitoba's
newest indigenous relations minister
gets schooled on residential schools
they thought they were doing
the right thing it was the express
intent
of residential schools to kill the
indian in the child
holy sh there's a tornado right there
breaking news a tornado touches down in
ontario the catastrophic damage and the
danger
from fast-moving storm cells and
canada's former top soldier
charged with a criminal offense
global national with donna friesen
oh my god i've never seen anything like
this in my life
this is very ontario where a tornado has
torn through the southeast part of that
city causing what officials are calling
catastrophic damage
some homes are badly damaged vehicles
flipped
police say eight people have been
injured power is out and emergency crews
are busy trying to restore it and make
the streets
safe i would refer to it as catastrophic
almost war-like there are homes that
have
been completely devastated and destroyed
there's rooftops that are missing
good evening and thanks for joining us
we'll have more on that tornado in just
a moment
but we begin in kamloops bc the tacoma
lipstick
chief calls it heavy truth the first
nation revealed more detail today on the
hundreds of suspected unmarked graves
near the former kamloops indian
residential school
an expert on ground penetrating radar
says 200 probable burial sites have been
found and that
further forensic work is needed to
confirm them
and she said the total number of remains
there is unknown
the kamloop school was once the largest
residential school
in canada less than one hectare of the
65 hectare site has been searched so far
the chief says they've barely scratched
the surface
you were bearing witness to a very
important truth
about indigenous people and canada we
are not here for retaliation
we are here for truth-telling
robin gail reports on the survivors who
told their truths today and what the
next steps are in the investigation
and a warning the details are
distressing
the kamloops indian residential school
has been closed for years
but it still evokes awful memories for
those who attended
the residential schools was built
to beat our language culture and
traditions out of us evelyn camille
spent 10 years there to cook and clean
for whom she calls the black robes the
priests and nuns
she left with a grade for education
that's what residential schools taught
me
to be ashamed of my identity
one by one the survivors share their
stories i was taken from a loving home
that only knew
humor laughter love
and honor
put into a cold stark environment it
wasn't by
family choice it was
the government choice
they got out but others didn't there
were stories of students being woken up
to dig graves for their schoolmates in
the orchard
back in the late 1990s a team of
archaeologists excavated a child's tooth
in the 2000s a tourist found a rib then
in may of this year
experts used ground penetrating radar to
search parts of the grounds
we could never say definitively that
they are human remains
until you excavate which is why we need
to
hold back a little bit and say that they
are probable burials
this new evidence shows 215 small
shallow plots consistent with
traditional christian burials
but who were these children the chief of
tekemploops first nation is demanding
the federal government and oblates of
mary immaculate catholic missionary
group
released the attendance records of the
students they were children
robbed of their families and their
childhood
we need to now give them the dignity
that they never had there's no guarantee
of accurate records
children came to the school from across
british columbia alberta
yukon and the united states these are
not discoveries
these are recoveries in some of her
first remarks as national chief
roseanne archibald says the assembly of
first nations wants the international
criminal court
to investigate what happened here as a
genocide this
is a crime against humanity
this is a crime against little children
evelyn camille has tried to visit this
site now closed off
but she is determined to protect this
resting place
those remains should be left
undisturbed a powerful voice of
determination
despite all the damage done to her and
so many others
the radar only looked at about 2 acres
out of 170 and it has already identified
200 other targets that could potentially
contain
remains and the new chief of the
assembly first nation says she's in
talks with the prime minister
to get funding to begin the excavation
despite elders wanting it to remain
untouched
donna so much more work to do robin gill
and kamloops thanks
there is some support for survivors a
24-hour crisis line is available for
anyone experiencing pain or distress
as a result of their or their family's
residential school experience
the number is toll free you can speak in
confidence it's 1-866-925-4419
manitoba has a new minister of
indigenous reconciliation and northern
relations and just minutes after he was
sworn in
he said this the residential school
system
was designed to take indigenous children
and give them the skills and abilities
they would need
to fit into society as it moved
forward that was immediately challenged
by manitoba opposition leader wab canoe
i cannot accept you saying what you just
said about residential schools
it was the expressed intent
of residential schools to kill the
indian
in the child it is not cultural
relativism
it is not revisionist history
for us to say that that was wrong any
right-minded person
at the time should have known that it
was wrong
many did know and speak up against it
there is more to the story brittany
greenslade is following it in winnipeg
tonight the statements were shocking
i believe they really did think that
they were doing the right thing in his
first remarks as manitoba's minister of
indigenous reconciliation and northern
relations
alan the controversy it hurt
that led to his appointment in the first
place
listen to the stories of the survivors
and i cannot accept you
saying what you just said about
residential schools
lash modier who is metis was appointed
to the job after his predecessor eileen
clark
resigned she quit after premier brian
pallister responded to the canada day
toppling of statutes in front of
manitoba's legislature
by saying colonial settlers did not come
to canada to destroy things
but to build up communities i paid
tribute to canadians
i paid tribute to pre-canada builders
i spoke about people who came here with
hope to build
families and communities i spoke with
sincerity
i spoke genuinely in a statement clark
says
i have spoken up on several issues but i
feel my voice and other voices were not
heard in cabinet
change is necessary inappropriate words
and actions
can be very damaging you can't be out
here defending residential schools
if you want to work with indigenous
communities
killing the indian in the child was
wrong
we all know that that was wrong so you
have to move past that
lajmodier has now tweeted an apology
saying he misspoke
acknowledging residential schools were
designed to assimilate indigenous
children
which was wrong then and wrong now
brittany greenslade global news
winnipeg a northern manitoba community
remains in a state of emergency because
of numerous deaths and incidents of
self-harm
nine young people from the tatasuya cree
nation have taken their own lives in the
last nine months
the intergenerational trauma that so
many indigenous people endure is still
going on
in some places it's getting worse david
aiken is following this story for us
from ottawa david
well donna the first thing to task away
act chief doreen spence and members of
her council did today
was to meet with local rcmp to find ways
to
step up campaigns to prevent illegal
drugs and alcohol
from being sold to underage members of
the community drug and alcohol abuse by
young people by teenagers
that was a big problem and was the
common denominator in all of the
suicides
but the aggravating factor has been the
discoveries of unmarked graves
at former indian residential schools i
think it triggers a lot of anger
a lot of trauma because uh
they're just finding out just you know
this generation is just finding out what
happened to their grandparents
seti is the grand chief of the regional
council of northern manitoba first
nations including to tasquayac
and he was in the community last week i
just
know that they will navigate through
this it's not going to be easy but they
will
and i have hope and faith that they will
navigate their people through the start
time but the community will need help
there are only two mental health
therapists in the community of 2600
and they work only monday to friday the
federal government is mobilizing two
more youth workers
and the canadian red cross is providing
funding for more training in the
community
but advocates say long-term supports
need to be in place
not just into taskway act but in other
remote first nations
we have to be very proactive we have to
think ahead
and try to reach out to the young people
because it's a very critical time
governments in winnipeg and ottawa
appear willing to respond
we'll continue to do everything we can
in our power to address these issues
the layers of grief and
intergenerational trauma experienced by
indigenous peoples are of particular
concern and that's why
we're continuing to work directly on
investments
for mental health and indigenous
communities and the crisis in
tatasquayak was on the agenda tonight
when
prime minister trudeau and the premiers
held their regular teleconference
meeting
as the country's first ministers seek
ways to better support the mental health
challenges
of the country's first nations donna
david aiken in ottawa thanks there is
some support available the canada
suicide prevention service line is
available in canada 24 hours a day
the number is toll-free you can speak in
confidence it's 1-833-456-4566
a big development in the allegations
against canada's former top soldier
jonathan vance
he's been charged with obstruction of
justice a criminal charge
he's been under military investigation
since global news broke stories about
allegations of sexual misconduct against
him allegations he denies
mercedes stevenson broke those stories
and joins me now
mercedes tell us about this obstruction
charge
donna a stunning legal maneuver to see
canada's former defense chief
criminally charged in court documents
obtained by global news
military police allege the former chief
of the defense staff
told major kelly brennan to lie about
their relationship to the police
lead investigator sergeant peter
charlesworth wrote that vance
between the first and third of february
2021
did willfully attempt to obstruct the
course of justice
in a judicial proceeding by repeatedly
contacting
mrs kelly brennan by phone and
attempting to persuade her
to make false statements about their
past relationship
to the canadian forces national
investigation service
contrary to section 1392 of the criminal
code
february 1st donna is the day that
global news
first called vance and asked him about
his relationship with brennan
he denied anything inappropriate at the
time
major kelly brennan spoke out to global
news alleging an inappropriate
relationship
with general vance while she was his
subordinate in his chain of command
including during his time as canada's
defense chief
she told global news earlier this year
that vance had attempted to get her
to mislead investigators after
global broke the story general vance
called you many times what did he say to
you kelly
told me to lie what did he tell you to
lie about
having sex he first started telling me
not to say anything about anything vance
is scheduled to appear in september
in a civilian criminal court global news
has reached out to vance for comment but
we have not yet received a response
vance previously told us at global news
that while he had spoken to brennan
he had not pressured her to say anything
or asked her to say things that weren't
true
it is significant that vance is facing
this charge in the civilian justice
system
that addresses concerns about whether
the military justice system would be
able to try him and is a direct response
to recommendations
recently made in a scathing report by
former supreme court justice morris fish
obstructing justice is an extremely
serious charge
vance could face up to 10 years in jail
if he is convicted
donna okay mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks
after the break we'll take you back to
berry ontario where that tornado touched
down the destruction
coming up
we want to take you back to barry
ontario now where that tornado touched
down the mayor says no
deaths have been reported but people
have been injured a command center has
been
set up for those forced from their homes
global's erica vela is in barrie erica
set the scene for us where you are
well donna right now there is the
command center
just behind my cameraman and there the
area is just
blocked off with emergency personnel
berry police have told me that anybody
who's they've asked everybody to stay
away from this area and they've really
called said that this area
is in lockdown now behind me is the area
that was
hardest hit by this tornado i'm just
going to step out for a sec to show you
some of the damage
this is about as close as we can get but
we have been hearing that
the damage is catastrophic now was just
after 2
30 when we started seeing that extreme
weather
some of it was captured on social media
there were dark clouds heavy rain
started happening
and it appears a tornado formed at one
point now this all happened
in the southeast end of berrien ontario
police say
they started receiving reports of strong
damaging winds
berry police began responding to calls
for property damage
the majority of the damage happened in
this intersection
that we are in right now maple drive and
prince william way
berry police say in total eight people
were taken to local hospital four with
serious injuries
but the cleanup here is going to take
days if not weeks and months
people who have been impacted have been
asked to go to this command center
but we are continuing to monitor this
story and of course we'll have updates
on our website globalnews.ca i'm going
to send it back to you donna
okay erica vela in barrie ontario
tonight thanks
ahead what's behind the decision to
rename toronto's dundas street
toronto city council has voted to rename
dundas street a major artery running
through that city
it was named after scottish politician
henry dundas his name will be removed
from other public spaces too
it's one more example of cities and
sports teams changing who they choose to
honor
and put on pedestals jeff semple
explains
it's canada's most famous intersection
young and dundas
is toronto's times square synonymous
with the city and its landmarks
but not anymore you can never go wrong
doing the right thing
toronto is renaming the street square
subway and all other buildings bearing
the word
dundas named after henry dundas an 18th
century scottish politician
who rejected a proposal to end the
british empire's
slave trade on favor kerry among those
in favor of the six
million dollar name change toronto's
only black city councilor
history will remember not so much what
it cost us
to change the name but it will remember
us whether or not we actually
take the right action our reputation is
on the line
dundas joins a growing list of
historical figures to be toppled
just steps away from young dundas square
this statue of egerton ryerson was torn
down last month
ryerson university's namesake was an
architect of canada's residential school
system
it's not about erasing history it's just
about who it is that we're
uplifting within our communities but
dundas's descendants
say his punishment doesn't fit the crime
he supported the abolishment of slavery
but promoted a gradualist approach
this has been like a trial where they
only heard one side of the evidence
the dundas debate is renewing questions
over which names and monuments
warrant removal amid a national
reckoning with racism
it cannot be just let's change the name
left you move
the monument let's look at the
fundamental way in which we have been
representing these people and how we're
going to go forward
the city will now launch a public
consultation with black and indigenous
community leaders to come up with a new
name
that process expected to wrap up by
around this time
next year jeff semple global news
toronto
next a residential school survivor
finally feels able to tell
her story
listening is the only way to understand
the intergenerational
legacy of residential schools in this
country today three women who were taken
from their families and forced to go to
the kamloops residential school told
their stories
one of them is evelyn camille until the
unmarked graves were
discovered on the school site she hadn't
even told her own children what she
endured
we leave you tonight with part of what
she said thanks for watching
my children came why didn't you tell us
i couldn't share my sorrows with them
our community was
one to look after each other
but these residential schools took that
away
from us our language
our way of life broken up
families broken up families still
happened today
with the child and family services
we have to end that system
and be responsible for our own children
in our communities
swearing up and down and when i'm going
to come up here i
want the truth to be out and i'm going
to be strong
but to think of what happened to
many children
the truth and reconciliation
i often wondered what the hell does that
mean
do they want to hear the truth really
we have tried to tell them the truth
and who are they who is going to listen
the residential schools were
specifically
built to take the indian
out of us to take away our language
culture and traditions
and to make us some astute
but it did not work
[Applause]
you